will not
die that was a scene outside of hedge
fund Giant and Harvard Alum Bill amman's
office of protest if you can even call
it that for the preservation of Dei
courtesy of none other than Reverend Al
Sharpton Amman of course has been one of
the most vocal critics speaking out
against his Alma moder's response to
hamas's October 7th terrorist attack but
it was his pressure campaign against
disgraced plagiarist Claudine gay and
her Dei agenda that really got under
sharpen skin we would not have to have
Dei if we didn't have de n y we were
denied Dei was to make up for the denial
historically of blacks
Dei is something we must have
equiz the they were able to end
affirmative action this is a war on
civil
rights joining me with his response to
the Reverend Shelby steel senior fellow
at the Hoover institution um Shelby
thanks for being here tonight how does
it make you feel given your own personal
journey and history and all that you've
accomplished to hear Al Sharon say Dei
diversity Equity inclusion is something
we must have to equalize the playing
field well it's painful to hear that uh
I can't tell you how how sad that makes
me
feel uh you know we we it's so it's so
sad that to what he is really preaching
is
dependency he's saying to Black America
particularly we can't make it without
dependency on the largest Society we
don't have what it takes to do that and
so our protest our moving trying to move
forward and advance in society is based
on our faith in on dependency of of
white to white
Americans and to
institutions uh and not in in what's
heartbreaking specifically is Reverend
Al's refusal to
acknowledge The Power Within Black
America that has lifted us sustained us
to this point uh and to ignore that and
talk about what some white man with a
lot of money did breaks my heart he
should be ashamed of himself you know
and black Americans need to understand
that the day is over for this kind of
Indulgence in the fantasy that that
dependency is our way ahead well and spe
specifically all of this is centering on
Claudine Gay's um resignation yesterday
as as president of Harvard but um
claudian gay in terms of her having that
position you know has never written a
book uh she's written I guess only 11
Journal articles and even yesterday um
you know when she resigned it was all
about her and the truth is that you know
I think it was McGill who was uh res her
presidency at the University of
Pennsylvania that had nothing to do with
color and yet Claudine gay had the
additional problem of 50 credible
plagiarism allegations don't they see
that does Dei withstand logical
scrutiny well this is one of the things
that that fascinates
me Dei would not exist were it not for
White America White America feeling so
so threatened by the the charge the
accusation of racism that they're
willing to give to hire people like
Claudine uh gay even though it's it's
obvious that she's not qualified but
white she's black and she's a woman and
thus redounds to White America a certain
innocence uh a weapon with which to
combat the charge of racism so she's
there because whites are have given in
to the stigma that they're all racist
that the country is racist okay uh
and I I I want to shift gears for a
second I I apologize I don't have a lot
of time in political News USA TODAY
kicked off election year with this
headline noting that a fraying Coalition
of black Hispanic and young voters is
actually abandoning Joe Biden and
pointing out that Biden now claims a
support of just 63% of black voters a
precipitous decline from the 87% he
carried in 2020 Shelby what is your
reaction to that I'm happy that that is
we're
slowly we're slowly uh beginning to see
the light uh of of how we've been played
we've been
exploited uh and we've been we've been
used over and over again affirmative
action uses blacks as Pawns white
innocence uh they who have we've had 70
years of affirmative action now and uh
blacks are farther behind than they were
back in 1964 when the Civil Rights bill
was passed wow uh is a it is a humongous
failure of public policy the greatest
one I think the greatest in American
history next to the Civil War and so
forth all right uh but it is profound
and
well Shelby you you are profound in what
you say and I wish I had more time but
thank you so much for being with us
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else